give me 10 seconds
we're about to be live
how are you brothers
with the kids man that surprised
podcast in the dunya the three muslims
today we're joined with who finesse the
man himself
the muslim baller masha allah
and if you think you recognize him he
actually has a twin that looks exactly
like him
how you doing
alhamdulillah
the realest podcast in the dunya thank
you guys for having me
um i saw a few your podcasts masha allah
you guys doing an amazing job keep it up
keep it up brothers you know you guys
are really uh putting a lot of things in
perspective being the voice of the the
young and the upcoming muslim generation
i think that's very important that we
have somebody to to tap in and a lot of
things that's going on
um
i appreciate it very much
man we got we got a lot to talk about
man we got a lot
you know um
we got a lot to talk about you know i
know a lot of people want to hear about
my marriage or marriages you know what i
mean that's always the hottest topic all
the questions
are
tunneled or funneled right through
the marriage and um you know basketball
being a you know a college basketball
player african-american muslim
you know so
you know you know my journey and and
studying islam and
you know
it's a lot it's not it's it's a lot to
talk on speak on hamilah
oh we're ready bro i'm sure the viewers
are ready too this is the
question that we're gonna throw your way
bro and while angel just fixes up the
tripod real
quick is uh how did she
bacon how did that name come through
okay so
um
i uh i think a good year ago i used to
go live every day i was very very free
you know i had a lot of free time uh i
started in ramadan
um i had a very loyal audience
masha'allah and um obviously uh
the live consistency consisted of a lot
of questions right and so one brother he
came online and he said listen um i got
a girlfriend i'm trying to do it halal
so immediately you know i say listen you
eat that halal that the hot on bacon we
only eat halal bacon and that was it
that
i mean you saw strips of bacon and alive
and then um
they started calling me halal bacon
every time i went on live he started
calling me halal bacon and i said listen
man put some respect on my lane shake
halal bacon aka hello hitch and then
that went crazy
but we stuck with chicken bacon
i just like halal bacon beef or i love i
love beef i like turkey but i really
love beef bacon alhamdulillah a lot of
people when i when i came out with this
with this name and i said listen maybe
just change my name out shake out bacon
i got a lot of heat from that you know
it's amazing how to you get the most
heat from your muslim brothers and
sisters you get the most heat
and it was like listen that's haram
why are you trying to make something
haram halal
what do i do so i kept it i said listen
if you guys don't know about halal bacon
do so google it go to shape google
is
bacon halal you see a lot of halal
places like midamar and a lot of other
um halal companies they actually sell
halal strips they're baking strips but
they're made from beef you know what bro
i gotta i gotta try the beef one too i
only tried the turkey one it's way too
salty bro it's way too salty listen
before she became muslim
she loved
bacon
and that's the only pork that she used
to eat
so when she took her shahada
she didn't you know she was like damn
man you know that bacon was good so i
used to bring home turkey bacon
she didn't like turkey bacon i was like
okay this only bacon we got and then
um i was the first um
influencer to collab with um
boxed halal
right they hit me up
and it was like yo
let's let's do a collab i said bet
i went through the inventory and i said
oh beef bacon
i said let me try that beef bacon
and so honda my wife tried it she said
this is better than the pork bacon this
beef bacon is
sizzling
you know what i mean
it's very expensive though you know be
especially the the halal me still around
the corner for me um they they sell a
little pack for like 17 20
you got like eight eight strips in there
you know may allah makes you easier
i can imagine bro
and then what about hopefulness how did
that name come up okay so who financed
is the combination of me who i what i
grew up doing i grew up playing
basketball all my life and then my wife
um
um
she always before you know obviously
when we got married she had a little
dunya you know a little daisy
and so she would say everything's
finessable
and so
get you know me and my brother we're
known to finesse the halal way of course
yeah we're gonna be you know you know
work our way into certain situations
work our way out of certain situations
and i would like and i'll be turning to
states if i this everything's finessable
baby you know everything's finessable so
i put hoop finesse together in class it
it birthed
the the who finesse uh wave you know
alhamdulillah
y'all got any questions bro
well i just want to know how you're
doing bro like it's been
that's how my senior was ramadan bro
yeah subhanallah man uh i've been real
busy i started um this basketball tour
uh last year 2021
and that's been keeping me a lot very
busy i didn't realize how
high of a demand
um
male muslim
influencers are i didn't i didn't know
that especially in the basketball world
and when i hit up this massage first of
all that that idea of having a national
basketball tour
it came from
my dinner that i had with stephen
jackson um i'm sure you guys are aware
of steven jackson martial a good brother
you know champion he took a shahada and
he's been muslim ever since mashallah
tabatal we were in atlanta i'm from
atlanta and hold on one sec guys you
guys are too loud you guys are too loud
thank you
um
uh sorry about that
and i was in atlanta he invited us to
his house
um last year um
and we were talking about dean
basketball and marriage you know that's
i mean what do brothers talk about you
know
and
i was like listen let's do a basketball
tour the three of us let's do a
basketball tour let's go visit all the
missages we mentioned some of the big
misagen in america that we always wanted
to go to
and everybody was silent
i said oh you brothers don't think i'm
serious i'm like i'm i want to do a
basketball tour i want to go
and tour the country and meet different
youth around the country and and have
that's all cast basketball tournaments
train them and so obviously stephen
jackson he's busy with his world you
know what i mean was his thing and i and
i understood that and my brother my twin
brother
you know mashaallah he's still a
professional basketball player you know
actually he made the venezuelan all-star
team
at 34. i mean he's in one of the top
leagues in the world mashallah and he
made the all-star team and he's actually
leading the whole
the whole league in scoring my shout out
to barticula
and so he's bawling he's bawling man and
um
before he went overseas back to his back
i think he was in at the time at qatar
or libya
uh we did a few camps together and
subhanallah we went to dallas we went to
chicago together and we did um new york
together and it's been a snowball effect
ever since then and you know i'm going
to dc soon insha'allah i'm going to uh
seattle um
inshallah utah inshallah fresno
california inshallah and uh then i'm
going to start the tour again 2023 and
shall we go in and go and return to all
the all the massages that i've been to
last year
and this year they they invited me again
alhamdulillah so it's a high demand for
basketball camps you know what i mean so
i'm happy to still be playing basketball
but it's more geared to
dean you know what i mean is more geared
to
focusing on the the basketball the youth
you know using the youth uh using
basketball to bring in the youth you
know let's let's suck them to the masjid
let's bring it to the mission this and
you know during my camps i have caught
at us you know what i mean we have 100
challenges you know a piece of party you
know i try to make it more than just
basketball you know so that's what i've
been very busy with and obviously um on
social media market islamic and you know
muslim brands and so
i'm my own manager you know everybody's
telling me mohammed you need to yo
you need to get a manager dog i said no
i love this process i love learning
this
field
and so by the time i i do hire a manager
i already know what to expect i already
know what to do already you know what i
mean so it's a process for me
alhamdulillah
sounds good it sounds beautiful man
like
if i wasn't in the masjid i was in a gym
i was in the gym if i wasn't in the gym
i was working with my father
and so that that that's our you know i
then obviously i got to sleep at home so
i had four homes working for occupations
you know work growing up as a muslim and
we've always wore our kufi we even
played basketball games
with our kufiz on my father was
unapologetic was an unapologetic muslim
music he and my mother were the first
muslims and still the only muslims in
their family you know what i mean and so
it's a blessing to have
muslim parents
and who are who are reversed and to live
live as a muslim suit
and growing up playing basketball my i
was homeschooled my father didn't want
us in public school
and he always had a chef come to our
house or we go to the sheikh to learn
the quran
alhamdulillah and and when we got around
1617 we just got very spiritual one day
we didn't want to play basketball no
more we had scholarships me and my
brother
if i mention some of the schools man
you'd be shocked you know what i mean
some big d1 schools play on espn every
other night you know what i mean my
shout out to article
we
we just we we left that to go to yemen
we went to yemen to study i stayed there
for two years he stayed there for like a
year
and we studied akita we studied um
hadith we studied a little bit of tafsir
and obviously we studied arabic and
people this is why i love arabic so much
you know going to yemen
and
learning the deen not only learning a
deen but learning arabic
and and now i get to use whatever arabic
knowledge i have very little and kind of
infuse into my videos but i think makes
them a little unique you know what i
mean and um
and it's been it's been
ever since i came back from yemen
you know
seven days later after i came from yemen
okay
i signed a basketball scholarship
the coach didn't even see me play
he didn't even see oh muhammad's in town
what sign still delivered he didn't even
see me play i met him the same day allah
i signed a full scholarship basketball i
was out of shape
hey i didn't play ball for two years
basically and oh well we did play in
yemen but i my mind was in it i was just
doing it for the money to pay the rent
masha'allah
um and and you know playing in yemen was
was was an amazing experience because we
got to travel to aaden
i mean you name it
we get we we traveled all of yemen all
the hot spots all the nice beautiful
countrysides the the mountain size the
villages the silks i mean we
had a full on yemeni experience at
hamila and we played for the moon
we played for the national yemeni team
okay we represented yemen's
and to this day saudi arabia remembers
the day we beat them we were the only
humanity team in the history of yemen
to beat saudi savannah
only team you know
and um
i'm going to talk about something um
i have i haven't gone public with this
and i think i'm going to mention it
think twice bro think twice you can't
you can't take it back
i think i want to mention it man it's
something that that was
you know one of my favorite stories and
i memorized it at this moment was a sort
of use of it
so to use
you know the trials and tribulations the
fitting that surta that
nabi yusuf
um
he experienced
okay
and
he was imprisoned
unjustly
you get on going
not you but no no way
yusuf was imprisoned unjustly
and
uh allah says but there is cinema
so some say around seven years a little
more little less
um and
me was seven months
but
seven months you were locked up for
seven months where
in yemen
wow no for what
for nothing
so they just they just pulled you aside
and it was like yo no no no that's it
got grenades strapped to their shoulders
aks everything
what's that what's your word i said
i said i'm a seeker of knowledge
he said
the
we're the students of information who
the heck are you
but you know it was a time where before
right before the war the war was on
brink you know the brink of war was
happening so i guess it was it was
national security you know what i mean
and um and and it was a very uh
interesting experience that you know i
don't want to go into details but
yemen still holds uh it holds a very
very dear
um place in my heart the people very
humble most of what they're in man very
humble people
very loving people um i used to have to
sneak out of the masjid
five times a day i prayed mashaallah for
two years i prayed in the mischief five
times a day
i used to have to sneak out the masjid
especially
um
okay i can do that you know what i mean
but the i sneak out the message because
i'm always invited to someone's dinner
lunch brunch
sneaker
you know we we love the other quad after
after the salah but sometimes man i
i duck out the mischief because they're
so kind and so um
um
hospitable you know what i mean and and
you images the people of yemen all the
people i met there mashaallah to barack
very very beautiful people it's just
unfortunate
that they're experiencing that's a test
from allah you know what i mean the
prophet saws he gave his prophecy that
there will be a lot of you know um
a lot of trials for the arabs and uh may
allah help the the people of the auto
you know a lot of people think oh
mohammed you're a black man why you
always cater to arabs like no no no no
it's not
i don't think i'm out of i don't cater
to arabs
i just i love arabic
i love the quran
okay
and
some of my
main followers my major supporters are
from the arab world
and i play basketball in the arab world
and when i go to these misagid here in
america they're ran by adams
when musa goes to play overseas goes to
the middle east you know we must have
won a championship in medina i lived in
saudi arabia for two years um after i
graduated college
um and speaking of college man
man that that was interesting
four years
black muslim
you know a practicing muslim you know a
lot of players may allah guide us all
they're muslim by name
the jews and christians will never be
satisfied with you until you follow
their way
so the coaching the coaching
the coaching staff oh they didn't like
me i didn't follow their way i never had
a girlfriend in college never drink a
sick out sip alcohol never been to a
club or to a party house party i never
when we went to the special invitations
in las vegas two years in a row we were
invited i never i never walked the strip
with them i never um went to the clubs
with them
smoked with them so i was a sore thumb
because as a team in america
you got to do those things you're not a
real brother until you we we you know we
sleep with the same girl or until we
smoke from the same blunt we we we not
bravo i can't trust you you know what i
mean who you might be one you might be
the fans or something you know i mean
you can't if you don't do what we doing
you know you you you're you're not part
of you're not from the brotherhood and
that's how i was treated
especially the last two years you know i
had major nba scouts on my tail man my
last two years but i came off the bench
i didn't play
the coach didn't even play me on the
seniors night
on seniors night as a senior i was the
only player on the team that didn't play
have you ever heard of this you guys
watched
college basketball college football
college sports
have you heard of senior night before
i've heard of it though
senior night is dedicated to the seniors
so no matter how important the game is
win or lose you got to play the seniors
sometimes the scene is start or to
finish the game in this case the game
that we are a senior game this my last
game of my career is the senior night we
get dedicated decorated we can have time
show we get the pictures family come
parents taking pictures it's our last
collegiate game of our career
and
with this game
whether we won a loss we had the same
position in the playoffs so it didn't
mean it didn't matter if we won or lost
we still had the same we were still the
fifth place of what a seventh place it
don't matter we were still the same
place so i'm like i'm i'm nervous
i'm ready to fall i'ma just shoot threes
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm crossing
somebody over i'm a waving a fan i had a
whole game plan well i he called the
freshman sophomores juniors seniors
walk-ons he not one mentioned my name
so it was a test for me man it would be
like
and allah saved me uh
you know and you know it's crazy
in in in the conference tournament guess
who played the most minutes
i did
i coach
do you want to play me now because you
don't want to lose we you feel like
you're close
to
the championship and you want to play
your best players
even the best player on the team said
that i was the best player on the team
in an article
and
the second team in practice would beat
the first team because of me mashallah
tabata
it was just very political very um
they discriminated against me and they
said oh it wasn't discrimination
listen you don't play a c or see your
night
you don't i i i used to travel like when
i packed my bags and we jumping on the
bus to go to away games or whatever go
to the airport the coach should be like
what you doing son i said what you mean
what i'm doing coach
he said now you don't have to come i
said what are you talking about
what are you talking about i don't have
to come
he's not we don't want cheerleaders i
said coach i want to support the team
yeah i say yeah i know but just hang out
with your family spend time with your
family
i stopped traveling to away games bro
healthy
healthy
in the best shape of my life and he knew
he probably knew i spoke to one or two
nba uh scouts he knew it and then in the
conference game after the conference
game where we lost
uh nba scout came to me he was like who
are you what happened
what happened so he gave me his card he
said what happened
you played so well
allah
and and that's that's my basketball
journey and then after college
um i didn't have no offers
they didn't you know the the manager of
that team didn't release
film like i needed game film to get a
job
he gave everybody game film except for
me
i said yo
i need the game film then these these
nba team uh night indian teams these
overseas teams they're asking for game
thrill like i know you have it you have
access to it oh no
you know what kinda
that's a super flaw and he was a he was
like bible bell boy you know
he loved you know he's a christian boy
and
i never
had debates or forced my religion on
them i just played ball i just wanted to
play ball have fun
but you know when you're different
especially
when it comes to the faith
it becomes a problem you know allah says
they like to
you know they like to bite their nails
they they bite their nails out of
jealousy
you know what i mean
allah says that they wish that they can
turn your you against your faith
out of jealousy
you know what i mean this is what allah
says they're jealous that we're on a
straight path you know what i mean and
um and then i i eventually play ball in
saudi and then teaching english and then
that's when my social media
um
journey started a lot you know on social
media i downloaded snapchat snapchat was
very popular i think it still is popular
i don't have snapchat now
but i think it's still it's still
popular in saudi
but at the time um this the students
like teacher you very funny very very
funny man
did get uh snapchat you must download
tamil snapchat now i said what a
snapchat okay i downloaded snapchat and
lord have mercy i can't stay on you know
i i did pranks i did islamic pranks on
taxi drivers i did uh random
conversations or interviews with saudis
with pakistanis with all the races there
that's that was there in jeddah
and it was going viral i mean super
super viral
and but it came with the fitna
okay major fitna like
like real time big time hot on fitness
you know and so i deleted it and i
didn't save
the videos i just deleted it i was so
the fitness was bad i don't want to you
know go into details but as the job you
know what fitting i'm talking about and
i was getting messages that i should not
have been getting
from
individuals and so you know it's
secretive so they feel like oh they open
it it's going
thank you for looking
it's not no no it's still here and as
you destroy me i deleted it and um came
back from saudi
i met stacy
okay met stacy we got married um
you know
we were driving in an uber
well i was i after like a few months out
my plan was to go back to saudi and
teach and play ball but when i came back
my for my first marriage you know i
married her years before i met stacy but
we were divorced obviously and she you
know she said hey come come take the
kids i said bet i've been fighting for
these kids for the past few years flew
to turkey whatever i had to do got my
kids and they stayed with me for a year
i was like damn you know i can't take
them
to saudi because
the visa doesn't cover family
it's a you know what i mean
i said what do i do do i
do i dip with my kids or do i try to
find another contract
so i said you know what let me enjoy the
kids while i'm here and i'm enjoying my
family my father
so i i started doing uber you know when
i went to the car dealership buy me a
lexus mashallah cash you know i had that
halal money that a-wrap money you know
what i'm saying i say how much i said
this i don't want to pay reba ain't no
reap over here you know i want penal
reba
which which city was this this is
orlando orlando okay my father loves
orlando
and he's from new york and my mother's
from atlanta uh from dallas georgia um
and um when he came uh to orlando he was
like this is it i'm staying this is it
right
and uh
i got alexis and i said listen i'm gonna
use this hybrid lexus to make some money
uh uber's popping in orlando at the time
it's like crazy competition now
i was driving in i drove downtown and
these two uh beautiful ladies walked in
the car
okay
and being me you know i got my coofie on
you know i'm saying i'm whipping that
lexus trying to get this money it was
four o'clock in the morning
she was like how tall are you first
question i said six four i said okay she
said okay you got the seat back and
she's like oh this man it's my friend
it's her birthday just stacy talking you
know and she's just she's spitting that
game you know she's spitting that game
and we're laughing
and then um i started
to
sense that she was very interested
obviously i'm interested too
and so i said okay let me
let me uh
let me get her number so listen uh
can i get your number you want to have
lunch tomorrow breakfast she said sure
she was like what so the next day i said
listen don't come alone bring somebody
with you you have a father you have
a mother yeah she said i'll be my friend
as long as you're not alone let's have
uh because we had we had a little dao
session in the car
so i i guess you know i was [ __ ] i know
[ __ ] i was like yo muhammad spit some
more dollar man you know
right don't follow the steps footsteps
with shaytan i follow them steps but i i
i think that
allah knew my nia was correct
you know
when i met her the first thing i said
first of all she ordered pork
right she had some bacon i said listen i
would have paid for both of your dishes
but this pork on the plate and i can't
buy the pores hot off for me
she was like she looked at her father
her friend like
like this clown what you can't buy no
pork i said no i'm not but i never
bought pork never will
and
then i told her listen i'm muslim
okay
how
and you know we can't do i can't touch
you we can't get a hug you want to learn
about islam and i broke it down and
collapsed the next day she was
what is this what is that before you
know it a month later i said listen hold
up hold up
i said
no this is like two weeks later i said
listen we like each other see you know
and i know we and we didn't say bae i
didn't call a baby i didn't flirt with
her i said sister you know i like you so
listen as a muslim
you want to do like
let's court halawa she said what is that
i said listen let's get married you have
your rights
um we have two witnesses you have a
mother she said what is a mug get a
diary you can ask for anything you want
she said i want a ring so i said bet she
said hold on don't send me the ring yet
don't don't let's not when i seen your
ring that means i'm ready i said okay
we're not going to talk no more then
when you when i get that message
with a ring the picture of the ring that
you want then we'll talk i said we ain't
talking i'm waiting for you let's let's
nip this in the butt
and so a few days later maybe a week
later or whatever she sent i got a
picture a notification
oh it's a ring she wants to get married
so i went and got that ring uh my thing
was from pandora
and um
we got married you know
and
a month later it was ramadan she took a
shot at her
she rolled around in the bed
she woke me up three in the morning i
said girl what are you doing it's
ramadan i'm about to get up for 200 in
like an hour you you got me an hour up
too early baby girl what you doing
honolulu she said i'm ready i said what
you mean you're ready
ready for what it's three what you
waiting for yeah i got work and i got a
fast she said i'm ready she had tears
down from her eyes i said oh subhanallah
are you ready
she repeated after me she took a shot
that's how she became she took a shot
and um that's how we got married that's
exactly how we got married and how many
she said mohammed no man has ever been
up front with me
honest with me respected me the way you
did he didn't try to have you know in
the course he didn't try to this was
strange to her
i prayed in front of her to see if she
how she react to the prayer i recite the
quran before we got married i recite the
quran to see how she reacted to the
quran i asked her listen as a muslim
if if we were to have children with a
muslim man this is how they will be
raised the children will be raised she
said okay i'm okay with that i asked her
i spoke to the mom you know what i mean
and and i wanted to see
especially stacy's reaction to islam
period
because marrying a non-muslim woman is
marrying a muslim is a risk
vice versa marriage is a risk there's no
guarantee in marriage
but to marry
a jew or a christian
you know this is very risky and i want
to say this to the brothers
brothers if you meet a sister in the
dunya in america it happens
you know we want to be 100 halal but we
have jobs we work with women
unfortunately we have go to school we go
to school with women unfortunately
we um just go to the gym la fitna
you know we want to go to la fitna and
there's this you know what they know
they said
you know what's in l.a fitna
you feel me
this is the society that we live in
so you're going to see these beautiful
women on a daily basis there's nothing
wrong with that try to lower your gains
if that's not helping the person some
said fast
if you can't fast no more you're losing
too much weight you know you know what
time it is you got to get married and
then i'm very unfortunate and a lot of
sisters got mad at me and my brother
for marrying non-muslim women
brother there's so many sisters ready to
marry you
why would you marry a non-muslim
she wanted a ring that was 100
you want 20 000
um a sister i can't afford you you are
worth a million you're worth you're
priceless but my price is very simple
your price is i can't do it monetarily i
can't do it
i can't afford you i was in like five
official another shuttle ears
in saudi arabia i couldn't afford them
i couldn't afford them they want this
they want
it's too much and i love i love my
muslim sisters but sister you know
listen sisters you gotta chill with the
mother and the sister stood up and she
spoke for the women she said but allah
says in the quran
we can ask for what we want or must okay
you want to make the hello difficult
make the halal difficult and this is the
fitna that's that that we're facing
today
the brothers don't see a future any time
soon of marrying a good muslim woman
because the family or whatever ask for
too much
and then i've seen
sisters that have no future because of
this and they do the haram on the low we
know this is a plague in the muslim
community
we've seen it we see our brothers do it
mankind was created weak this verse is
inserted nissa is in sword chapter of
the women
talking about and you read around the
verses you read the tough serious verse
and you know it's talking about you know
fornication lord negaze and all that
stuff uh you know getting married
we're weak
so you make the most simplest thing in
islam is to get married there's nothing
more simpler than to get married
hey i gotta i gotta sit down before i
drink right you know
you know if i do a video and i drink
standing up oh it's haram no it's not
haram to drink standing up habibi it's
just it's
better to sit down you know but getting
married is easier than drinking the
water you know what i mean it takes five
minutes to get married five minutes
five minutes habibi but
allah does not want to make things
hard for you allah says in the quran
he wants to make things easy for you
okay
he wants the thing he wants
you know
allah says in the quran he wants to make
things easy
and so
um
that's my response
stacy and my wife before that
she was i gave a shout out to this my
wife before that i gave her shahada
before i married her
okay she's still a muslim to this day
masha'allah
she's still my you know
my brother's close friend with you know
my in my in-law my sister-in-law just
went to [ __ ]
she married another muslim man she's i
get listen i get all her you know what i
mean i get all her uh
even though we're not married anymore i
get all her achievements
but i said listen she went i bought her
ring for like ninety dollars
i bought stacey you know i just recently
upgraded her you know a little diamond
piece and diamond set mashaallah tabata
can i give him a shout out
you know
what
allah you know allah says in in in to
spin from what he has
allah says in the quran and if he has a
lot then him spin if he has a lord he is
limited let him spin for what he have
but if you're making the halal ease
very difficult
what is the resort
you see and that's the problem and so my
advice to brothers when they get um
if they meet a sister who's not muslim
see her reaction of islam
meet her family
make sure you know
don't you don't as long as you know that
she's thinking about you know she she's
she believes in allah she believes in
god she believes in isa
you know she believes in the angels make
sure she has some core beliefs and
to be honest nowadays
it's so hard you know it to marry a
non-muslim is
it's very risky
because
we're living in bad times you know these
aren't the same christians and jews as
before you know what i mean
and so it's a very i always say do not
marry with hope hope comes after
marriage i hope we stay together
where you don't marry someone hoping
that they'll be what you want them to be
big mistake is that what i'm saying and
so
but with my wife i met sakada i had man
i had an ease filled with her very
i had sekina in my heart very it was i
wasn't nervous i wasn't like oh should i
do it it just went naturally everything
was allowed it just went it went so
smoothly and a lot a year later she
started wearing that hijab
i never asked him to direct hijab
i never asked her to take those crazy
pictures off instagram like you know
before she went from bikini to burkini
okay burger she went from bikini to
gilbert
literally mashallah without me
telling her
we have to learn how to remind each
other of allah and yes
so
yes we are the greatest people to emerge
of mankind we forbid we encourage good
forbid evil
uh uh you know not ten hundred
right we forbid evil and we believe in
allah but how do we do these things how
do we forbid evil how do we encourage
good
we lack
in hikmah when it comes to these two
things
you see what i'm saying so i wanted to
be as
have the best characters possible
dealing with my wife she came from a
very harsh
and traumatic background
so if if i was harsh on her where did he
jab you gotta pray five times a day you
gotta learn al-fatiha what's wrong with
you oh habit
i don't want you you're i am
allah the process of some said the women
are made from the rip you strain out too
much you're gonna break them and this is
what the woman's doing we're breaking
the women
we are break i wanna i wanna talk about
two things
and you guys cut me off because i can i
can talk for three hours and not even
realize it you know what i mean i want
to talk about the hijab real quick
inshallah
okay i want to i
i really want to want to break down the
hijab the best way i can inshallah okay
starting with the quran right
the first verse was from sorta nor
allah starts with
ashley let me let me see we always talk
about the women
we don't talk about the men they're
hijab they're hayat their
their their their uh their modesty we
always
are on top of women your hijab incorrect
why you wearing makeup your clothes are
too tight brother you're playing soccer
and it's halfway up your lot like the
shorts are halfway up your leg your
[ __ ] is showing and you're in you're
being a keyboard warrior and you're
telling your sister a strand of hair is
coming down haram this is so shame on
you sister
brothers
stop
gaining up on the sisters
it's hard enough that they have to cover
the most precious thing to them is their
beauty it's a especially in 2022
we have access to social media we want
public validation competition it's a
plague but
with hikmah
you know we always talk about women what
the women should do what the women
should wear how do we should wear what
they should what about the men
what about these brothers on social
media showing their chests
that's not modesty the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam nor the
sahabas never went outside uh without
we came to pray with our shoulders
showing only
that's one shoulder
we can't even pray even even in israel
when we pray we have to take the strap
and cover the other shoulder while we
pray and then after we pray we continue
our um
we have a modesty too the prophet saws
was building a message in medina
it was very hot
he took his shirt off
put it on his shoulder to carry the
stone of the message and he fainted and
when he woke up he knew why he fainted
he fainted because him being outside in
public with his shirt off
was not modest
it's not modest tai chi is not modest
tight shirts we're showing the form of
our body it's not modest yes the aorta
the private part is from the navel to
the knees
but still we can't just casually i can't
be on this live right now with my shirt
off
my abs my chest my wife like yo what are
you doing you you you thirst trapping
bro
and modesty
having modesty it
it it amplifies the love between a man
and a woman when both of them are modest
it's amazing
i lower my gain she lower her gaze
i don't touch other women she don't
touch other men
i dress modestly respectfully and she
only knows who's under these clothes and
she dresses modestly respectfully now he
knows
we don't know what we're missing
you know
so brothers
allah told you first the hijab in the
quran
you know
you know
allah says you know
for the men first lord again just the
hijab of the eyes
and then he told the men to guard the
chastity get married boom and then
the verses for the women came
but it had a little more instructions
with the women and i want to talk about
the hijab real quick
the the the verse it goes from
the same orders glory against women
guard your chastity sisters
okay don't get you know get married
before you do you do
but then there's a one-two punch
that allah did for the women to protect
them you see clothing
comes all the way from adam alaihis
or whatever her name was may not forgive
me because you know there's some
difference between what her name was you
know
when they were cast down on earth they
felt the shy and they felt the shyness
so they started covering their private
parts their oda
out of modesty they didn't feel that
agenda they felt it in
in this earth
and that's why we feel something when we
see a woman don't
a sister can be walking away from us and
we still trying to look at something now
that she thought
she could be walking away and we trying
to see what she working with i hold the
election what
what we don't even need to see the
sister's face
and we it's a trial for us
and it's a trial for the sisters too
okay but one but allah says well they
said
the man is not like the woman
the man is not like a woman okay
so anyway there was a one-two punch
allah says
allah says
that barrier that women should have
and it's all for their protection and
that that protection part goes into the
next verse i'm going to expound upon
real quick inshallah but allah says
after
guard your chastity uh after lawyer
gates to the women guards your chastity
then allah says it do not show off your
beauty
what happens when a woman shows up for
beauty she's inviting
unnecessary unwanted attention oh you're
a prayer why are you looking at me girl
you showing me some
what you talking about while my look
i'm trying over here but you do you know
do you know that men
the first sight the first looker of men
is the breast
look it up google it what is the first
thing men look at and how long it's 85
percent high baby less than 20 percent
look at the face
you know where i'm going with this less
than 20 percent look at the face
we look at 80 85 and another uh um um
study said 47
first thing is the press and list listen
to this verse allah says and do not show
off your beauty
accept what is apparent
means
the face
in the hands
this is not the order and this is i i
agree with discipline that is not the
order of the woman
ill
accept what's apparent thereof and and
obviously
the one
all you guys are beautiful mashallah
oh you're you're handsome
do i blame your your your beauty that
allah has given you do i blame you oh
sister why are you looking at my boy man
what's wrong with you
no we we all have our parts
and i'll give you an example real quick
and i'll get back to the verse in the
quran
was a very handsome
sahaba he was so happy that when ancient
gibraltar used to descend on earth he
used to take the shape and form a father
to the point where i should sometimes or
whatever anger will see father and say
yo you know she would tell the prophet
yo that's father coming now he's the
apostle said no that's that's the angel
jabril
this is how handsome father was so
father was with
allah
this
so the hadith gave the same adjective to
both father and the beautiful woman
very beautiful woman and father or
kenner rajulan was the end
okay a very handsome man
okay so this woman was beautiful
she asked the prophet saws can i make
hajj
for my on behalf of my father because he
says over at old age
he said yes
the prophet islam is interacting with
this beautiful woman but guess what
father was doing y'all know what father
was doing
he was not lowering his gaze
this is a sahaba
at the time of hajj
in front of the prophet salallahu salem
not lowering his gaze and you know what
the prophet saws did did he call the the
him did he scold him what's wrong with
you why are you looking at this woman
you're weak you're
on my leg shame
what's wrong with you he didn't scold
him
did he call the woman why are you
causing fitness to all these men around
here we're making omar why are you
coming outside like this your husband is
a do you do you have a husband or he's a
do you do you have a father he's a do
you whoever is your male guardian there
do you did you call him what do you
the prophet islam he just took father's
head chin said turn away from her
that's it look at the clock of the
prophet salallahu
look at this beautiful verse in the
quran look look at the state of the
ummah right now
allah says o people do not scold
one another
do not do not ridicule one another like
yes
do not ridicule each other
perhaps the one who is being ridiculed
is better than the one who's doing the
ridiculing
i didn't say it allah said it
you you may be ridiculing somebody on
instagram oh brother
that brother might be better than you
that's your muslim brother don't
ridicule him
and then allah said well and he
and for the women do not really kill
each other perhaps the woman who is
being ridiculed
is better than a woman who is doing
ridicule
subhanallah well they're telling me so
insult each other you calling me out of
my name this is insulting if you don't
call me a muslim
yeah mohammed yahoo
you're insulting me i can't call you out
of your name this is insulting i cannot
ridicule you it is insulting allah says
do not insult each other have you read a
hadith with process some and sought to
someone
he had a list of munafi kun he knew
every monastic ever he entrusted this
list with yahya
i believe his name
he gave him the whole list of monash did
he call one more one muslim in the ranks
did he
can he imagine if i knew the oh you're a
monafic you're a catholic
haram he can't do this
and then allah says
well that's
not called bad names
you call her brother the youth because
his wife shows his her face you call him
under youth
you calling me out of my name [ __ ]
after i ain't i have to have faith i i
believe in allah
i believe
i believe in this you call me out of my
name habibi
you're just giving me as you're moveless
you're becoming a muthaless a muffler is
the person who was bankrupt the process
some said who is the mufflers
they said the saab is easily a muflis is
a person who had money ain't got no
money he broke
he
brother broke the processor said no the
mufflers is a person who comes on
yamakayama with his salah with his zakab
with his hajj with all the good his
fasting
he insulted this person he killed this
person he shed the blood of this person
he backed by this person
he stole from this person all of his
passanat the salawat and his fasting it
goes to his victims
you're giving me your husband your
brothers you're giving me your
astronauts don't cut listen
i'ma get to do youth later inshallah i'm
gonna go back to the verse
then allah says
after allah
all the many majority of the ulama they
say that means
her aura is everything her whole body
except the hands and face
read it i think albany wrote a book uh
jibab or something like this he wrote a
book read it
okay
and then uh the same verse allah says
beautiful and i mentioned
that the first thing the men look at is
is the breast
the bosom listen to this verse allah
says and
they the women
should take their him
and and this is homur
cover your breasts
look at the hickman of allah's final
donald
look at the heckman velocity copy of
breasts
that's very modest now he ain't got
nothing to look at
and then this in the studies it said
like less than 20 look at the face they
look at that the waist
like 40 looks at the waist in the bottom
and then they work way up subhanallah
look at the hickman of allah
to take the because before these verses
they used the word the women it's the
head piece
that's the meaning of
what the woman uses to cover her head
so but they used to take the ends and
throw it behind them
and so their neck their ears i mean it
was like you know we seen sisters with
bandanas on well you know how this
that's a little trash why ain't gonna
lie you know her neck is showing oh lord
i gotta lower my gaze this is she
she fitting her right boom but then
allah said allah tweeted hijab just a
little bit he tweaked it
they already had the khimar on they
already covered the hair they had you
know they were back a little bit and
then they pushed it back and it was just
you know what i mean when after this
verse
just cover your breasts boom cover your
ears your neck boom okay
this is
or the hijab nowadays we call the hijab
okay
this is
so brothers
if you're blaming a beautiful woman
you're saying brother sister you're a
fitnah
she's dressed
modestly you're the problem
you're the problem her oda's not showing
why are we putting so much emphasis on
women why are we blaming and talking
down on women
why are we doing this why why is this
energy shifting
the blame to women oh you you what you
more you want you gonna cover their hair
she didn't cover everything and you
still blaming her
you still
did the process not blame that beautiful
woman during the hajj
did he no
because we're we're human beings and you
know what the jicama of everything even
nikobi's i don't know love nick
obviously stacy she's trying to ring the
call for a good minute i was very happy
when she wore nick off how many love it
took pictures i was like oh yeah i got
my wife she ran the car but you know it
lasted not so long but she felt
uncomfortable with us and there's no
blame allah says this and that other as
long as you you know you you dress
modestly and whatever and
you cover it and you know do your best
right
but
i've seen
negabies right
you're right they had to take off in the
airport you got to show that face
the the basis
the source of identity
is the face and the
hands fingerprints
the heck of allah
so it's not a sin for her to show her
face
she's got to get id
she got to travel get a passport
she might get put over by police a male
police what you gonna do oh it's haram
no it's not a hybrid it's not a sin
shoulder show the officer your face
before you you get like oh you you might
be an impersonator
the heck my velocity
talk to me shay it's halal baking time
shake the heck of allah's final dollar
the second verse and i'm going to cut
this quick inshaallah allah is
he directly
i mean this is serious this is how
serious the hijab is
this is how serious modesty is allah
spoke directly to the nabe
say to your wives your daughters and the
believing women i mean that's every
woman who claimed to be muslim
masha'allah
okay
the to the nina
okay to throw over
the jilba what is it
in in in arabic i believe is molabis
vasya
loose cloth a cloak
loose clothing so yeah it's covering the
bosom and you have the jillbag wear what
you want sister but where's something
that's not and sisters say why we gotta
wear loose clothing where does it say in
the quran sister jilbab
if you look up the meaning of is a loose
cloak it covers the whole body
okay it covers the whole body the jibab
is in the quran
okay
says with your cover your bodies with
okay
why but why
i know the sister saying why why i gotta
i want to show my beauty i'm beautiful i
want i gotta seek what my mama gave me i
gotta show everybody what my mama gave
me
allah
that's better for you that you're not
overly exposed for what
there's so many evil men out there look
at the the human trafficking of women
alone
look at the sexual harassment at work
look at the sexual harassment at at at
school look at high school the women are
the women
are
are traumatized in high school by the
time they reach college they're already
traumatized they hate men basically
because
they
showed them
exactly what allah says do not show them
just show your husband don't don't show
them all that the cleavage don't show
them
show cause look if you show that brother
that you're not thinking about your
personality
he don't want to know your name you
don't care
you've already triggered him
and i so i always say and this is why
they call me halal hitch i always say
men don't have switches
we don't have one enough we just on
women have switches
on off they're turned on they're turned
off you know if they see a handsome man
oh he's handsome he actually keep
walking if a brother see a beautiful
what
do you see you feel me it's a difference
allah says
what
this verse allah says so that you may
not be overly exposed and known
to just random men especially in in
even online but especially in per in
person you're vulnerable sister you're
very vulnerable
they're picking up women in orlando
that's the capital of human trafficking
because everybody the sun is out every
woman want to be
you know what i mean the beaches are
there cuba's there
the islands right everything
everything's the border everything
mexico is there
well not mexico but the border
and philadelphia so that you may not be
harmed okay we all get harmed
i'm like i got jumped i'm from the hood
from atlanta from the hood okay i got
jumped i had guns pulled on me i'm from
like my my dad didn't handle my we lived
in the hood okay we were
you know below
you feel me
so i experienced racism from cops
getting jumped fights i experienced that
even in even going to homeschool we
still went outside to play ball we still
went outside to hang out you feel me
but
not the harm that allah is speaking
about in the quran
so that the women won't be harmed the
sexual harassment
the the manifestation
the vulnerability that women have in
certain workforces in certain
environments where men
see the opportunity to take advantage
you got married men trying to take
advantage of women you got single men
trying to take just evil men you cannot
protect i can protect myself ain't a
woman gonna try to take advantage of me
i mean she can try to seduce me but she
can't make me it's my choice but i can
make a woman you see the difference so
allah says for that you think
so this is the hijab brothers and
sisters brothers focus on your [ __ ]
man
focus on your thighs when you're playing
soccer and basketball when you're boxing
or whatever you doing pull-ups on
instagram covered put a shirt on
brothers before you tell a sister to put
on a hijab before you tell her sister
you know bran nikob yes the women were
nikabs at that time but it's not
obviously the process of uh provost
islam was sitting in the house
asma
bent abu bakr
the daughter of abu bakr walked in on
her he turned he lowered his gaze he's
old he said listen
he said
at the age of puberty cover your whole
body accept have that wallahi
he said except this
in this
and this is
he authenticated this
another hadith
said do not cover your faces and wear
gloves in the time of
obviously that's throwing two points one
women there wearing a cob and gloves
and two it's not it's not the ora
so
for you to call me or do you
i asked so many brothers
i said brother
you married that's my first question you
know i i do i do enter out into my
comments good comments and bad comments
i love interacting with mine i do and i
know you guys noticed it i love
interacting with my followers i think
they deserve it i love my followers and
my messages are
over like
it's crazy but i do try to respond to
some comments and some uh dms you know i
love to see the joy that i responded to
them and they're happy that i responded
and it brings joy to me well i my
followers they're the reasons why bylaws
finish i keep pumping up pumping this
content alhamdulillah because i get
more love than i do that the youth
statements you know anyway
i said brother you married to yeah i
said brother does your does your wife
cover her face what does that have to do
with i said this is a simple question no
she don't cover oh
so does she go grocery shopping does she
does she go to the gym
does she go to school
also men can see her
does that make you a duet my brother no
but it's diff no it's not different
it's not different a million men see
your wife and a hundred thousand see
your wife there's no difference
you're calling me at the youth because
you can see my wife's hands and face
what about you brother how many women
can hold
that high iman of ayat
as the wiser processor and the women
that were with the wise of the process
they they covered their gloves and when
they heard the word the verses inside
buhari when they heard the voice versus
um verses of the hijab you know they
they covered their whole body you know
facing everything dif i mean they're a
man who's super superb the process i'm
never ordered to cover your face
show me one verse show me one hating
please please show me please please do
my be my guess
so but he did order the
he did order
the
of the on the bosoms he did order to
jimbab
he did say that
because look look women are struggling
with the hijab alone
you want her to cover a face suit and
wear gloves
i've only seen like five women in my
life in america that wore gloves i've
i mean show me a group of teenage women
that wear nikobs hijab jillbob and
gloves
you gonna be that hard on our sisters
and then you're still gonna blame them
because now you're telling them to stay
in the house
brother
the women are human
the women are human
you
live your life brother you oh i said
okay um
i guess i'll just you know have fun and
make videos and then my wife i tell her
don't have instagram don't have social
media don't have this don't have these
things don't post you can't do nothing
and she see me doing everything i tell
her not to do
that
just sister post we have earl and matt
from women they don't we're nicole i've
met a man's wives who studied from
graduated from azeroth graduate from
madina university
they don't wear niqabs does that make
them a dude does it make me mad to you
we have emails for do youth now
look at the state of the um
well that's telling me something full
circle man don't don't talk down on
people and don't not call people bad
names especially out of out of out of
ignorance there's two hadith about these
two hadith about you very simple
and i love arabic so you know i'm gonna
read them in arabic
one hadith talks about three people both
of them talk about three people that
don't will never enter gender allah
won't look at them you know what i mean
you know how it goes
uh a drunkard
a woman who touched
you know she looks like women men she
intentionally dresses to appear like a
man and a do you and then the other
hadith uh one who's undutiful to the
parents a drunkard and
the youth so do you says in both of the
hundreds
one of these says
at the youth
the prophets of islam gave the meaning
of the youth so why are we giving our
own meanings why are we giving our own
interpretations of how do you
that's not fair who are you the prophet
sallam gave the matana of the youth
the process some said the youth el levi
rajul al-levi
he agrees with his wife that's like
fornication it's adultery it's the
ultimate kabbath evilness
of seeing acts
as you agree
that your wife is fornicating hobbit is
filthy you're saying that if a woman
covers uncovers her face and her hands
she's coveted
come on man
come on shay
and then the other hadith allah the
process said i do you because the sahaba
said what is it the youth
a man who
la you believe
that's even more
detailed than the first one i mentioned
a man a youth is a man who does not care
who enters his wife
you call me at the youth
i saw brothers like you know how many
you know we're considered celebrities
whatever you want to call it
i never consider myself a celebrity you
know what i mean it's kind of weird to
me you know but hamilah we're at these
events whatever and brothers want to
ask states the question hey you want to
meet my wife you want to you want to
post this hijab for i don't mind
i i step in between i said yo yo happy
birthday in anything this is my wife you
need oh yes like yo you're too close
bro like you talking too he almost knows
his nose with my wife see
we still have to lower our gates allah
says in the quran
for the men and women it don't there's
no conditions whether she's fully cold
or fully naked we start to lower our
gaze
there's no conditions of lord against
the
the commandment the umar was lori
against men and women so if she has a
nick off don't be looking at her eyes
trying to oh man she got pretty so she's
beautiful
brother you you're the sick you have the
sickness not her
if she's wearing a jig by but she's
covering you can't see the form you're
trying to wait till the wind blows
hold on let me wait
you have the problem habibi
you are the problem don't blame her we
always blame the women
allah says we can allah go for the
rahimah after
the verse allah is forgiving look at
look what after giving instructions for
the women to where jibab allah says what
can allah go for rahimah allah is so
forgiving so merciful look allah so now
we got sister struggling with hijab
guess what allah is to go for a raheem
allah knows she's trying
allah knows
that's not the use
i'm not a dude
now
if i was promoting my wife like yo
take
loosen that up and you know tighten that
up
you know what i'm saying like
no i'm entering the realms of the youth
but still technically i'm not into youth
because the process said
you bali
man
that's the ultimate
hobbit bro that's the ultimate
disgusting act is a man say yo
dude
she's foundation go ahead
a lot of the processes i'm didn't
mention the later in knows hadith not
one time the word was mentioned so don't
say a youth is a man who has no here
that's obvious he has no reader i mean
that's
but what is a hater
we don't know what hira is man we think
leaders i'ma snap a dude if you look at
my wife
he said if i saw a man with
my wife with that means obviously doing
to do like you know
if i saw me with my wife he would catch
my sword
so so the sahab was like yo that's crazy
the leader said process i'm saying are
you astonished by his leader but i'm
more i have more than that and allah has
more than that and
is provoked
by disobedience
this will be not supposed now you're
provoking his leader
you know what i mean it's very vengeful
when you when you especially in public
you see what i'm saying but that's
that's unto you that's the leader
is protective jealousy if you look up
here in arabic you have words like honor
protection
so what is
we protect our women's rights our
the men of the community
are the protectors and maintainers of
the women women no women should work
ever in the muslim community ever
a lot of say the husbands are the
maintainers of the wise he said the men
make because you put a woman out there
to work you're putting her at risk she's
she's working eight hours with johnny
and she's only spending two hours with
you
what you think gonna happen you know how
much how many affairs happened at work
she's taking advantage of oh she he
makes me laugh
because we got gained brothers know how
to get you know me
oh she's emotional so she's sad at work
they had an argument because they only
spent two hours together because this is
working too
so she go to work happy to see johnny
johnny make her laugh brings her coffee
looks at her certain way compliments her
the brother you know they've been
married for five years you know his
compliments kind of kind of kind of wind
it down a little bit you know what i
mean he kind of got you know comfortable
but he's she getting all the validation
from johnny at work for eight hours
so that's why the men are retainers and
protectors of the women obviously it's
not hard enough men women to work but
she should take he which environment she
work at you know what i mean
so
that so that's
that is the the protection leader is the
protection of the women so you look at
her a certain way i'm i'm
yo ah
lord that i like the brussels song he
protected that woman when
he said father come here he protected
her
and he protected him
he didn't scold nobody he just turned
his chin [ __ ] he was like yo i can get
that he's handsome he know he can get it
he looking at it like yo
he oh the processor had leader
for that woman that he didn't even know
that's later
that's protected the leader you see you
see your wife she's wearing something a
little tight like though says i can uh i
can say yo you you kind of rocking that
thing back there come on now you gotta
hurt me out
that's the reader
that's the leader um yo babe you know
let's not post that man because let's
read let's re-record that because uh
your neck is showing or maybe i have to
blur it out that's rita
don't tell me i don't have leader i hate
when like brothers be telling me i don't
have leader i said i'd be i'd be wanting
to threaten them sometimes yo talk to my
wife see if i don't have a leader talk
to her
you know what before she started running
hijab the first year of our marriage it
was very testing for me i i low key and
i told her this i wanted to like leave
her
because i couldn't take it because she
would receive so many messages from men
and we had access to each other's
instagram each of the phones we're just
opening couple michelle we still like
this you know
so
i was like yo another dude man you know
like yo like he trying to speak into my
wife so i re i respond yo man uh you got
something to say my wife bro are you
crazy i'm sending a voice message to the
guy who tried to hit on my wife
that's rita yo you can meet me i'm in
orlando bro what's up you going to talk
to my wife you know she married but you
know she wasn't wearing her jab she was
you know she was showing a lot of stuff
you know what i mean
and even verified accounts music
producers singers like the
inner dm's i was like
i was i was told my dad i said yo pops
man
i don't know man she she's not wearing a
jab i don't even know why i did this bro
i i thought she was to wear it and you
know she had one point where she kind of
veered away from islam for like a minute
i think she was going through some you
know
and i was like yo she she showed me one
side and now i see side b i don't want
to see side b i want to see side a if
this marriage is going to work
but the uh i mean ma'am i spoke to a
very respectful man masha'allah he's
imam he said muhammad
you love her i said yes
do you think she loves islam i said yes
does she
go against i said no he said be
patiently dua and we'll lie um
i'm making one of my favorite duas that
i still make
to this day and i and i i have it
probably only four people noticed so now
the world ones whatever i said y'all a
lot when it came to my wife ya allah
guys guys thank you
thank you
i said ya allah
correct my mistakes and fix my errors
i'm about to do
i want to move to hajjib i don't know
what i was thinking but the feeling of
sekina was overwhelming i i just had to
marry you know what i mean anyway
a year later she started running hijab
and then she went from caked up face to
minimum mystic i was like i hate
lipstick
hate it
hate it with a passion never liked it
all the wise i've been married to i let
them know
that's your face do what you want with
it but i'm not a fan of it i love
natural beauty so marshall not about it
to you do what you got to do and so she
went from bikini and kicked her face to
jab and minimum
makeup i'm happy with that
well life
i'm happy to see my wife make that
180 and to love the hijab i never once
told her to put on a hijab well lie i'm
happy with that allah increase her of
course we brothers want some super high
man righteous women they don't even step
outside how many women are you gonna
find like that
good luck brother
and she's beautiful and she's
educated and this and good luck with
that brother you see what i'm saying so
i'm very pleased with my wife with her
covering she's you know she she loves
fashion she she's been a muslim for four
years
do you expect her to be like aisha or
the law and how
come on
and then the videos that we post
masha'allah i've given shahada to
couples i can't even count how many
couples i've given shout out to
alhamdulillah they didn't they said we
didn't know that muslim couples had
relationships like we just knew that men
beat the women that's all he knew
subhanallah
many sisters every day she gets a dm i'm
bringing hijab because of you thank you
sister
i mean
so you waited out the good obviously
brother if i told one brother i said
listen if if my wife's face is too much
fitting for you just just block me or
just don't watch my videos i'm not doing
it for followers
so
just look away i cup i i follow couples
who do videos together focus on the man
in the video
i watch it one time before oh that was
funny like a comment oh y'all i love
y'all my channel and i keep it moving it
don't bother me the launching is showing
you know what i mean and i'm like yo
hold up hold up she's showing too much
because
that's what we we're inclined to 85
we focus on the breasts 85 percent bro
that's a high number
you see
and so that's my journey with my wife in
terms of her taking a shahada and
brothers always ask me i got brothers so
many and i if you're watching i'm sorry
if i have not responded to you
but you're not the only one bro you know
a lot of brothers married now muslim
women
and they're asking me for advice
my advice to them is the advice that the
process islam gave to aishwarya
he said have two things you can beautify
any situation patience and kindness
actually
the hijab and that came 13 years after
that came when their man was high so
brother focus on her understanding of
who allah is increase her eman and
she'll do the rest well i should put on
hijab because one is she gonna be like
yo allah watching me oh i got i gotta
ready to see jack just don't feel right
that's from the e-man
he will teach you knowledge is connected
to taqwa
teach your wives
knowledge
that's one of the rights that your wife
have on you is that you must teach her
you don't want no dummy for a wife
islam promotes education amongst the
women
that's her rights you get the knowledge
from the mischief you come back home you
have a class with your wife
your teacher you're corrected during the
day
you correct answer quite don't even know
baby ask me later i'm a little bit busy
no brother hold on let me put this what
you want what question you have babe
okay yeah yeah you can't do that okay
let's research this together okay i'll
ask any man teach your wives especially
when it comes to like pollution and
stuff like the brothers you can't just
be marrying sisters and she don't even
know what pollution is about
she think you cheating the halal way
like
brothers
you gotta educate your women so they can
educate their children and so they'll be
confident in why they're ready to hijab
they'll be confident of how to be a wife
how to be a mother come how to pray
some of our wives don't even know how to
pray but we want them to write their
hijab
your wife is not even muslim and you're
for yo you can't wear that bro she's not
even muslim you can't force her to be
modest
she don't have no iman allah the process
said
they like twins
modesty and faith are like twins
okay and if one rises the other one
rises
if one other then he said if one it
decreases the other one decreases
they're like twins
that's iman in high the more a man
someone has the more hayat
someone has
you see what i'm saying the more amen so
get feed her you mad feed her knowledge
of the dean love her love the heck out
of her treat her like a queen
bro you can marry 30 women
if you treat her like a queen like allah
commanded you to allah says
she's not gonna leave you
i'm not i'm not i'm not promoting
politicians by the way i don't know hate
okay my point is women are very loyal
and they're loyal they can be loyal to
good men and unfortunately because of
their nature they can be loyal
to bad men if i start selling drugs i
hope states that i'm like yo man i'm
what you want me to pack you know i got
i got the ounces here and got the bricks
you know what you i hope she obviously
tell me yo that's not wrong you know i
mean but women are ultra
they're loyal they're very they're loyal
they're more loyal than dogs i don't
care what anybody said
ain't nobody more loyal to women
especially if you're good to him
so
treated like a queen salting her heart
with with with akhlaq and adam and then
teacher and with this she started
growing in islam she said my husband i
love my husband not because i just love
him because what islam has made him my
man is a muslim man and i love him you
don't think she's going to follow why do
you think allah has allowed us to marry
the christians and jews of all the
muslim of all the mushriks allah
believing slave is better
than a non-believing slave uh
than a mushrika
than a kafir
even if she amazes you
but we have allah gave us some slack he
said
two mushrikas we can marry a christian a
jew why do you think we can marry them
obviously
they're that close they're very close to
allah already
just be kind that we can spread islam
through marriage
okay and that's the best out of
allah says that we are majoring to
nations
what's the best way of getting to know
somebody marry into their culture and
marry them
you know so
that that's that's my journey man i hope
i haven't overspoken man i'm sorry bro
i'm sorry brother just like bro we just
we just realized we need you for part
two bro
a lot of stuff man may allah
sometimes i can get in the zone in the
class you know i lose it and i hope you
if you guys have any questions man you
know we can just stop here or whatever
and ask me questions i know you probably
have things to do probably talk like two
hours already so um default i mean
you know and it yeah you know i
you guys like my
another marriage advice i will give
is you know they say how do you find the
right one they think me and stacey we
found the right one listen there's not a
right one
brothers sisters please
even the prophets islam even even in the
quran and twice in the quran allah
threatened the wise of divorce with the
worst
pay you bad say you're bad bicker allah
says i can give i got better women than
you virgins and maidens what
so you want the prophet salallahu
they said we want the prophet so
obviously they don't pick the prophets
of islam but so that you know they had
trouble too
you know processor was sitting and aisha
was in her in his face she was going in
like that
and abu bakr came in here at the ruckus
he was going to like swing on her
yo don't hit my wife you crazy
but then my wife
this is my wife let her get hurt letting
her get it off her chest i'm that's
that's a man bro allah
he sit there and took it like a man like
it's going to say what you got to say
i hear you
that's a man a man is the man who
doesn't
a strong man is a man who who he doesn't
take advantage of people because with
his strengths as the process some said
process
he controls himself in anger see that
inner
the inner self
woman
whoever fears the position of allah
and and and controls his nufs
his place is genuine
his place is gender allah says in the
quran so the process he took
so
that
is my advice
is there's no
perfect
match-up there's no couple goals you
know i mean i don't even get at least
couple please don't say a couple i say
much but jenna is is ghosts that's if
she's my wife and jenna now we can say a
couple goals we make an agenda yet
so i tell brothers and sisters
like a few steps when they want to get
married when they're trying to find a
wife first of all i have the nia
in them
intentions are
from their
their actions you know actions are based
on their intentions at the process of
someone
so when you you got to see the sister
hey you got to see the brother you can't
marry him because oh mommy said he's
she's beautiful or
daddy said he's handsome no no no meet
the brother meet the sister how do you
feel when you first see him that that
initial feeling is very important first
impressions is is is a term for a reason
are you attracted to this person
physically emotion are you how do you
feel what energy because your souls
probably already met before we were
bodies
you can feel it you love a brother so
much man i know i met you in
before we came in these bodies i know i
know we were brothers because that's the
hadith you know what i mean
so how do you feel what's the energy
that you feel here
especially with the brothers you know
sisters they look a little beyond that
they look at education and look at what
he can provide is he strong is he tall
you know is he this how was his height
you know what's his job you know but we
we just boom oh
if you're like ah she's all right don't
do it brother don't do it i don't care
how much you feel a lot don't do it
oh but man she fear she wasn't don't she
wasn't don't let the hijab fool you out
marry a sister depressed a man came to
the process of some sahaba she had so
long going to marry a woman from this
tribe he's the first thing he said he
didn't say my broke
he said did you see her
no go see her
the sahaba used to sneak around like yo
okay that's the wife i'm a married right
there
but you have intentions to marry her
they had to see when i was in you know
one of these arab countries i don't want
to mention that the the country name
but they said showcase their their
daughter's like you know i was like at a
at a you know a car show much
i'm not saying women are cars to stop
for this new generation no
okay
but what i'm saying is it's your right
as a future husband
to see her
as she is
right the xena a good part of the xena
the hair she can wear little tight
clothes if she wants this is
my opinion this is a pain that i follow
and this is saudi arabia you know
i'm like yo i'm looking too much that's
your daughter ah you know what i mean
look
you know what i mean
um so see her that's my first thing the
first the second thing is her akhlaq
check her out
she has good manners she has a good
reputation the people talk good about
her and vice versa
her o'clock personality and then her
dean her dean her dean you can have good
deed but very bad manners you don't want
to
process some sense learn the manners
before the dean teach your children
madness i die before the dean
isn't you got these scholars you got
some scholars have bad
luck like dude
many of the scholars i believe shafi and
many other scholars they used to sit
under
just to study their o'clock first
and then they took the knowledge so
akhlaq is very important
you know you know
allah says
you know what
you know it's afternoon
you have uh i believe i'm beside that
verse uh incorrectly but you have a
great akhalak
all right
right
and
that's what i tell people to look for
the looks not only the physical look but
your vision when you see her him how you
feel
if you like this
next step a clock dean
and obviously you want to check out the
in-laws you want to check out reputation
like you know already trustworthy are
they loyal
are they respectful
all these things that really hold
together a marriage and obviously you're
not gonna check off all but just some
boxes you gotta have
like you
you know you can't marry someone you're
not attracted to you can't gotta have
that box you got to
and yes the process i'm saying you can
marry woman for her her beauty her
lineage her wealth and
allah said the brother he said foreign
but there's a balance to that as well
you can't like i'll give you the first
divorce from a woman in history of islam
the first divorce it's from jamila her
name was jamila it's crazy right her
name is jamila that means beautiful
she was married to
he a top 10 sahaba top 10 top 15 sahaba
he top he taught his creme de la crumb
he's mount rushmore sir marshall
marshall he's guaranteed basically
granted gender this is fabit
right he had a little money so he gave
her a garden for him and
he she went to the prophet saws and and
see that's one thing about
like
these these new
brothers that
yo you can't be talking to women no
women spoke to the processor i'm about
menses women spoke to the process i'm
about marriage
once once a hobby and she said he's like
this
you you feel me you
they spoke to hell obviously there's a
gauge the lord again and everything but
they you can interact
stop this oh
don't go to mass ignora and and they
call it mass fitness hi baby happy
birthday we're lorna gays i went to
island chicago i didn't touch no woman
i didn't stare hair in her face
i enjoyed the islamic gathering okay
obviously we can do better in
separating the men and women we can do
better but what can allah go for
allah forgive me but anyway
she went to the process on sicily
i want to spit in my husband's face
listen to terminology mean i can't i'm
not feeling him at all
i'm not for them at all and she said i
don't see no problem
with two things that the process some
said look for
a clock indeed i don't see no problem
with these two but i cannot give him his
rights i want to spit in his face
this is stabbing she said i saw him
amongst other men
and i realized
he ate my cup of tea
he said are you willing to give up the
maha she said here's the keys right here
to the garden boom divorce
the first hola in islam you have the
right to be married to who you want to
be if you are pakistani you want to
marry a black man you married him you're
arab you want to marry somalia you marry
them if you're if you're a white man you
want to marry a puerto rican girl or
whatever the case may be you marry who
you want to marry and no one should stop
you from doing that this cultural
marriage is disgusting to me now please
forgive me if i'm offensive because we
have made islam hard i've seen so many
college students because i do msa events
i've seen so many sisters and brothers
come to me yo i want to marry
what's wrong
i want to marry this person but my my
dad don't approve him or prove her why
not oh she's not from my race she's not
from my tribe are you serious ah are you
serious
are you serious man you're gonna stop
your your son from doing something halal
because of race
something with that hip
they say
if this is the reason and it's a clock
and his dean is good she can go and
do her thing
with it you know go find finally
and marry and marry him or her and vice
versa
to protect from fitnah the process some
said if someone comes to you to marry
your daughter and vice versa and you are
pleased with their deen in akhlaq
marry them fazo we drew
this is the commandment from allah from
the prophet
allah says and say if you love allah
follow me allah will love you forgive
your sins so follow the stone of the
process
the process said the nikah is from my
sunnah whoever doesn't practice my
sunnah fellaini
he did not from me if they don't
practice my sunnah
and the processing system he said
and if you don't do this if you don't
marry that brother or that sister off to
your child and you're pleased with their
deen in the clock
first
temptation
corruption
facade corruption in the world you know
what this temptation is you know what
you know you know what's going on behind
the parents back she wants to marry
michael a revert of five years he got
tattoos on his neck he's attracted to it
he's reaver he's from philly and he's
dean and he got noor on his face he's
praying all his prayers he has beautiful
o'clock he was like armada before islam
and now he's soft like omar after islam
that's what she wants let the woman
marry the brother
care about he allah forgave him of those
tattoos she wants a a bodybuilder and he
was you know he did this he did that's
what women are attracted to
so
no
i gotta marry my cousin
i got him married are you
my cousin
they lose hope in marriage
so that's my advice in marriage and i
don't want to stir up no trouble you
know don't don't disobey your parents
but there's a balance to build wallade
as well and i don't want to get into
that you know there's a there's a
balance with bitter wild
righteousness and obedience to the
parents there is a balance and
swan allah
uh we all would love to continue this
month unfortunately we do have to end it
here i'm so sorry man i know man you
guys got it
we gotta blink twice you know i mean you
gotta blink twice
they weren't they weren't ready for your
energy martial was amazing we got to do
this again we got to do this yeah
anytime shay forgive me if i was too
long i know so long please forgive me um
and um you know if i made any mistakes
in my column it's just from me mail i'll
forgive me anything good is from allah
bless you
your marriage your kids your family
everywhere
may allah bless you brothers thank you
thank you for having me will i anytime
y'all hit me up man anytime man it's
true we're bringing you back to you and
exactly may allah bless your challenge
to grow may allah bless you to reach
millions may allah bless you to
to to you know to control the narrative
of of you know you know muslims
especially in this new generation
because we need it and you know you guys
keep doing your thing man keep doing
your thing if you have any more
questions any questions just let me know
if not we can we can do a part two
inshallah inshallah